Camilla deshaylis or D shalu I'm not
exactly sure the pronunciation is a
congressional reporter at the Washington
Post she did a great thing where she
spoke to a bunch of residents in George
Santos's District who voted for him and
here is what some of them had to say
about whether they want Santos to go do
you feel like regret for voting for him
yes of course
and he has no experience I am outraged
right
and the idea that he should uh you know
be able to remain in office is ludicrous
when you voted for him what was your
initial like why you wanted to vote for
him oh he seemed to be you know somebody
who gave a damn about this neighborhood
and they cared about people in general
so they thought that he really was going
to make some kind of petitions right I
just wish 49 why do people lie he
shouldn't be in office yeah so
um Santos in insists that none of the
people that voted for him want him to
resign but it seems that they do and I
continue to be disturbed by the ease
with which none of this stuff surfaced
before the election and you know again
I'm not necessarily pointing fingers but
opposition research didn't turn it up
and um journalistic work didn't turn it
up it seems like if you go to get a job
at a cell phone store you were vetted
more thoroughly ultimately than than how
George Santos was vetted now this news
spoke to high schoolers from his
district who will be able to vote in the
next election here's what they had to
say
Schreiber High School in Long Island's
Nassau County is in the heart of
Representative George Santos's third
congressional district
I mean I think he's an embarrassment and
a pathological liar true we sit down
with a group of AP U.S history students
at Schreiber high they are 16 and 17
which means they will all be old enough
to vote in 2024. how many of you would
register as an independent if you
registered today
not many of you would register as a
Democrat all but two how many of you
would register as a republican two of
them
their history teacher estimates
republican-leaning students are
outnumbered by Democratic leaning
students by an almost two to one margin
at the school but I haven't found one
kid who is sympathetic to George Santos
they know the importance of the numbers
in the House of Representatives and
although Santos represents them for
issues that they agree on
they don't have sympathy towards men 16
year old Taj parekh is one of the future
Democrats I think it's it's a very scary
situation for us having someone who is
so clearly lied and so clearly fabricate
his entire resume uh representing all of
us sixteen-year-old Nathan Jackman is
one of the future Republicans I like how
the Nassau GOP came out against him but
obviously Kevin McCarthy should come out
against him true and they should have a
vote on the house floor in order to
expel
put every single member of Congress on
the record I want the liar to stay or I
want the liar to go
um we this guy's got to go and I every
day that goes by that he remains in
office I worry that he is going to be
able to stay if you want to check out
these clips I've played we'll have them
all on our Instagram which you can find
by searching Instagram for David packman
show we're going to take a quick break
what a program we have for you today